thank you thank you donna moanin wrote
that for the invitation and for you
staying in the bitter end so I'm going
to talk about two different projects
dealing with modularity this is a topic
that I've been obsessed with for a while
now I'll talk very briefly about the
older project just because it has a
networks contact and spend more time on
the other that deals with 3y data so the
first project is dealing with the
integration of two biological networks
this is the work of tedium our was a PhD
student in my group ian is actually now
a postdoc here at the Simon's so we are
looking for combining two types of
networks that share the same nodes but
have different semantics for the edges
so the same vertex set for H and G and
we want to summarize this information
from the two network in something that
we quoin a module map and the module map
has nodes that are modules namely sets
of genes from the vertex s or vertex
subsets and we want these modules to
correspond to highly connected sets in
the first network in H on the other hand
the links in the module maps are
connections between two modules that are
highly highly interconnected in the
other graph in G so here is an example
so where the rare the black edges are in
h and the blue edges are in g and we are
looking for
modules like these three guys that are
highly interconnected in age so think of
them as clusters in age and they should
be connected by links which are highly
interconnected sets in the blue graph in
G and we want this we want to avoid
singleton like this namely clusters in
the first graph in H which are not
connected to anything in the second now
the rationale of this problem the source
of this formulation comes from work that
we and others have done on combining
genetic interactions and the protein
interactions so the simplest case just
look at two modules so you are looking
for two sets each of them reach with
protein protein interactions and between
them the connections are rich with
genetic interaction and the rationale
would be that perhaps we have two
pathways or two clusters and each of
them can be a backup to the other
however if you heat one gene in a
another in B then you get the
you get the static effect and therefore
you see a lot of genetic interactions in
between and a lot of protein
interactions within and when we analyze
this by looking justice pairs like this
we realize that sometimes we are missing
information and we want to do this
globally so just drink doing it one pair
at a time we miss some of the
information so this is a formulation
that so this is what will be the module
map in this so a node corresponds to
dense black sub graph and Link
corresponds to dense interconnections in
the blue subgraphs between them and as I
said this is a generalization of both
clustering the generation of the black
sites and by clustering the
interconnected pills so I won't get into
the algorithmic details we tried about
10 different combinations of violence
and we came out with what we call a mod
map algorithm so we get it starts by
building a basic initial solution using
maximal by click and emulation and then
does global refinement based on a
probabilistic score so maybe this is the
main contribution here because
algorithmically we've been using tools
and ideas that have been around but how
to compute efficiently a probabilistic
score that will give a single score for
the whole sub network that we have now
is been a challenge and we really we
successfully applied it both 20 yeast
ppi in GI data yeast ppi and specific
DNA damage response genetic interactions
here of course the network would be much
smaller because there will be fewer ddr
specifics and on completely different
not we also applied
to lung cancer data where we had the
gene expression of patients and one
network H correspondent to core
expression and the other network
corresponding correspondent to
differential coexpression between the
cases and controls and they are indeed
they're revealing combinations of
modules that you find by looking at
these two together so let me now move to
the second project and this is about
three way data I'll talk a bit in more
detail about it so this was led by DD mr
again and in collaboration with Danny a
cootie earliest statistician at Tel Aviv
The [ __ ] cuts another PhD student in my
group and tal mahender Hitler who is a
brain researcher at the earlobe Ospital
and here is the outline let me just move
ahead so again we are talking about
module so another way to think about
modules suppose we have this matrix and
clustering is just a cluster would be
just a set of froze that behave
similarly across all columns and a by
cluster would be a subset of the rows
and a subset of the columns that will
have some co here show some coherent
behavior and of course by clusters are
more flexible they could overlap and the
search space is much richer but we are
we've been talked thinking about
three-way data so in addition so think
about having multiple time points or if
you wish each matrix would be maybe
genes times time points and you would
have multiple matrices for multiple
subjects and you want to find some kind
of
a modules that are common to some or to
all of them so we have a matrix for each
subject and the Rose could be it would
be the measured object so genes would be
a natural possibility here and the
column would be the time points and what
would we would measure would be gene
expression so this is one application
another application which actually
motivated this work to begin with was a
MRI data so in MRI data what we have is
measurements of the amount of activity
in the brain in voxels which are cubes
of one millimeter on each dimension so
you get about a hundred thousand of
those in each measurement and every
three seconds you get such a measurement
so you get about a hundred time points
you have a matrix of a hundred thousand
times about the hundred for each patient
and if you want to are somehow reduce
the dimension rather than dealing with
voxels you can deal with parcels which
are contiguous brain regions that are
believed to help some biological
function so you could reduce the number
of the the number of rows from a hundred
thousand to maybe a thousand okay and
then the data that Addie was studying
was a behavior of the brain at rest so
turns out that when our mind is resting
as far as one could rest in an fMRI
machine which is pinging like hell when
the mind is resting there are certain
networks in the brain that wake up and
start to work so we don't have a full
understanding what it is but think about
it like garbage garbage collection
you know when you don't have any other
task the brain is doing some maintenance
and the point is that these sub networks
arise and the show activity but of
course when you summarize the
information across multiple subjects
they will be taught complete synchrony
between the networks in different
subjects and also this activity does not
go along the 100th time points that we
measure it will show up at a certain
interval and maybe disappear and show up
again so we are looking we want to
cluster this data we don't want to do
some dimension reduction that will give
us a meaningful result but we have to be
very flexible about the modeling we
cannot do like a three dimensional sub
cube of the of the huge cube that we
have and hope that with rigid dimension
we will get a meaningful result so if we
had just a two-dimensional case we are
looking for something like a by cluster
and this is a well-studied problem that
many including gas worked on it in the
past but what about consistency across
multiple subjects so now we have
multiple matrices like this and maybe
not all of them show the effect so out
of the five maybe three have some
coherent behavior and also this behavior
as i explained may not be on the same
time point for each one so the time
point could change from this one subject
to another and the gene said the subset
of the rows that we want to analyze
should have some common core but we
cannot assume that exactly the J the
same set of rows will be involved in
each subject because
maybe some are irrelevant and maybe
there is some subject specific part that
we should account for so this was our
thinking and the this brings up this
kind of fair way to visualize the
problem so here we chose this set of
subjects and there is this common part
denoted here by a which is the set of
genes some of the subject may miss some
of those and the sub each subject could
have also a private part to the same
very module ok so what constitutes a
model in this threeway data we have a
subset of the subjects subset of the
rows corresponding to this a part and
the subset of time points for each
subject and additional subject specific
part which is a subset of the coral
module so most of the rows will be
common but maybe not all an additional
say subject specific parts or additional
this dark blue rose are subject-specific
so how shall we what shall be looking
for we want modules with which are
unusual compared to the background so
either unusually high or unusually low
values so assume the simplest thing that
one can assume that there are two
distributions one for the values in the
background and one in the values within
the modules so the white part will have
one distribution f0 and the blue parts
will have a different distribution f1
and if the data is binary then just
think about probability of one being
higher in the blue part and in the white
part and if we're talking about real
value data just assume that we have two
normal distributions and the
for the blue part will be will have a
higher mean so these are the simplest
assumptions what could make for binary
and real value data so we represent this
model pig named in a graphical model so
in our toy example we had to choose the
subject so one part and then the Kouros
so we need to we will have a variable
corresponding to the relevance each
relevant subject and a variable
corresponding to each row for the core
module that we choose and once we have
chosen the set of subject we combine the
information on the core module rows in
the relevant subject into a note that
will also represent the subject specific
information and another variable will
take care of the time points that as I
said will be subject specific so on this
level we have the global information a
subset of the subject and the khoros and
on this level we have the subject
specific information and what ties this
module together is the fact that this is
governed by these global variables so
when we compute a posterior based on on
this model so since it's a bayesian
network we can just the
multiply the conditional probability so
this corresponds to the hyper parameters
of the problem this correspond to the
coral and the relevancy of each subject
this part corresponds to the subject
roles that depends on to these two
variables for the time points therefore
the data that we used we applied some
Markovian assumption because we assume
that we don't just get an independent
set of time points for each patient but
there is some contiguity not complete
but partial continuity between the model
the columns and eventually we compute
the likelihood of the data which is
simply we multiply across all all square
or only Q sub cubes in our matrix where
we either pick up the background
probability or we pick the model
probability depending on whether this
point depend there belongs to their one
of the module so I didn't describe the
hyper parameters but we made the
simplest possible assumptions so we were
using Bernoulli or normal for f0 and f1
and we use the better variables or
simple markup model for the rest so the
algorithm may we call it twigs for
three-way model inference we are give
sampling so the initial solution is
generated using by clustering solution
we tried both by max which is it will
very good enumerated solution for
discrete values for for binary values
and the is a from Nam ibaka is group
that works well on
continuous data and the improvement is
done we are Gibbs sampling so if i give
sampler namely each time we fix the
values of all the variables and we
compute the posterior based on that
single variable and improve and we do
this cyclically of course the technical
part here is deriving all the
conditionals and i will skip it here
eventually we end up with a local
optimum surprisingly it worked very fast
so we needed less about 50 iterations
and what we do at the end is you get a
value on each iteration for each of your
variables and we just average over them
and this algorithm just finds a single
module how do we deal with finding
multiple modules one possibility is to
start from is zero x max by getting a
complete solution namely a set of x
clusters and then run gibbs on each one
separately you get a set of modules and
you do some filtering to remove
redundancies an alternative which is
even more embarrassingly simple is just
to pick up the best from I see or hear
or x marks run gibbs on it and get a
module and then just mask over the
entries in the in the cube that were
obtained with that belong to em so this
is a similar to the classical church
algorithm that was the very first
attempt to do by clustering at
around 2,000 and this is repeated
several times so we did some testing on
simulated data so 500 rose 50 time four
points 10 subjects and we planted 50
core modules of about size 20 rows each
these are the noise probabilities and
this is a probability of adding private
row for each row separately and be here
you see the results for binary data and
for normal data these are they the noise
parameter for noise in the data so we
applied by Max is a separately edit also
a buy me gifts and the masker two x
marks and the other combination it turns
out that the best combination that is
consistently the leading one here is x
marks + Gibbs plus the masker and we
call this version twigs and this is what
we used from well now on interestingly
even if there is no subject specific
information so if this piece 0 value is
0 we still see an advantage over the
pure by clustering solution so here is
one application this is has to do with
the sepsis data so then we had the
measurements off on
expression for a 14 subject and they
were measured on five-time points0 time
and for additional age and we did the
simplest thing possible we just
binarized the matrix and comparing two
times zero and taking the four chains
and ended up with some 6,000 genes and
when we apply twigs we got two core
modules so module one contained 11
subject in 53 core genes and when we
tested for enrichment it was enrichment
for enrich for response to bacteria
which is make sense and the second
module was smaller but similar number of
genes and it was enriched with t-cell
activity so again a result that makes
sense and when we zoomed in and we
wanted to look at the private part of
each of each subject so the red the red
bars indicate the subjects and each one
has four time points so and the red ones
are those that are belong to the module
so you see that they are different
between the subjects of some contain all
the four time points others contain
fewer and in green you see the
enrichments on the private part of the
module in each subject so for example
this subject 24 his private genes were
enriched with cytokine mediated
signaling pathway etc etc and you see
that typically the there are not many
enrichment but there were two subjects
that had the substantial number of
enrichment many of them in common and
indeed these two subjects are the ones
that did not survive the septic shock so
there is some indication that we are
grasping a meaningful information
in this model here is another
application so this comes from the fMRI
analysis so the data that we had was 20
subjects after a reduction of the data
we had some 500 parcels and 94 time
points and this is the data that
originally for tal Mahendra's labs and
we found the four or five core modules
depending on how we define the
parameters but the content was very
similar in both cases so the partition
that this these modules give of the
brain makes sense to to our collaborator
the brain researcher because they fit
functional regions that are known to be
related to rest and interestingly there
were four subject that had additional
enrichment for a region of the brain
that corresponds to attention and the
hypothesis that can be that was made by
our colleague was that there could be a
subset of the subject that at the time
of rest they are more distracted or
attentive if you wish to the sensory
stimuli during this rest process so this
is part of the subject specific
information that we get now if we look
at the
a different subject we see that first of
all the fraction of shared parcel that
are covered differs substantially among
the subjects and also that the number of
time points varies substantially among
the subject so we did use this
flexibility of the model both in terms
of the core module definition and also
in terms of the time points involved if
we compare the two application these are
of course completely different worlds
and completely different data types in
gene expression we notice that the core
modules are relatively small and there
is a very large subject specific part
that is added in in this application in
contrast in fMRI the core modules were
relatively large and there were smaller
more modest subject specific additions
in in both cases the integration the way
the model was defined was crucial to to
obtain the results and we find that we
do find subject specific information in
each now when we compared it to a
variety of methods that were did
something similar to three way analysis
from the literature we see that twigs
covers the largest number of subjects
compared to all the other methods and
substantial improvement and also if we
will try to use some rank that
summarizes both enrichment and the
redundancy twig first better than the
other methods so it has some merits so
to summarize we came up with a
probabilistic model for analyzing
three-dimensional data and one of the
generalization of this model was
allowing the core plus subject specific
information and another dimension was
allowing the flexibility in the time
dimension the third dimension we develop
the evasion model and they keep sampling
algorithm and it performs better than
the extent methods are interesting even
when there is no added information
beyond the pure by clustering tasks and
we do see a great improvement in terms
of covering the subjects and we applied
it both to gene expression into fMRI and
in both cases we observe that the
integrative analysis was crucial to
obtaining the results we have in our
implementation and of course this is a
very first step and there is lots of
room to improve both in terms of the am
way we define the priors we use the most
simpler simplistic and naive assumptions
there is no subject dependency and the
parameter one could apply this also to
DataDirect were there is no time
dependency and there are many ways to
take this forward and finally let me
thank my group and my funding sources
thank you
questions
really single
well this is functional MRI and this is
the normal size of such studies it's
about the hundredth time points yeah
that the problem with correlation this
is what many people do I think the most
popular tool in this field is I see a
independent component analysis but the
problem is as I said that the
correlation is not global there's at
least in rest studies if you are doing
what what this community calls a
paradigm so I don't know you you have a
specific trigger and then you tell
people to raise the left hand or to
count backward then everything is
synchronized but we are dealing with
completely in synchronized data because
it's at rest and therefore correlation
is problematic it has to be global it
won't be global and its location will
change in a sense it's similar to what
you are describing you have much you
need much more flexibility Oh
well if two objects have an influence on
each other so the signals generated by
the objects follow each other within a
small intervals and this method k street
form to generalize to dead case so
you're talking about what type of data
start should be nine next objects start
showing up evenly the next objects are
showing a little leader for example so
they tickle each other yeah so I think
in terms of the time series you could
define some something a bit more
sophisticated than just Markovian
dependency so you could if you know this
dependency or you know the structure you
could tailor it into the model you have
different subjects
like
so what is the cushion
you mean ah ok so this is hmm you're
right every brain is different and we
need to do this mapping but there are
standard the techniques we didn't do
anything special we use the standard
techniques that are doing this mapping
and of course this in and edit the
source of noise and this is one more
reason to work with parcels and not with
voxels because you're much more easily
off on the level of this individual
boxing questions
let's thank the speaker again you
suffered